hi in this video we'll talk about
captain now captain are small molecules
with relatively simple chemical
composition which are not immunogenic
they're they cannot itself create an
immune response but they might create an
immune response when they're attached or
conjugated with the carrier want to be
noted that the carrier might be immuno
genic itself or might not be now we know
anything that binds to the t-cell
receptor or the b-cell receptor which is
membrane bound antibody is known as an
antigen now antigens can bind to the T
cell or B cell receptor but not
necessary they would evoke an immune
response so T cell receptor and b-cell
receptor binds to a specific epitome of
an anti antigen right now on the other
hand side those antigens which can bind
to the T cell receptor or T cell
receptor and can evoke an immune
response those are known as immunogen's
so that is how immunogen's are
differentiated from antigens now HAP
tails are not immunogen's by themselves
because captains are too simple you know
when the antigens are going to be
presented to the T cell receptor they
have to be served on the platter on MHC
+2 now MHC class 2 has a peptide binding
groove that binds to 16 to 18 residues
long amino acid now let's say the hapten
like this which is basically a benzene
ring like structure it's like too simple
to be specifically bind to the groove of
the MHC class 2 and presented as an
antigen so it hardly binds with
specificity in the MHC class 2 whereas
peptides derived from several pathogen
which has a length of 16 to 18 residues
can easily bind to MHC class 2 peptide
binding groove and can be presented to
the t cell or b cell receptor and if
they are able to activate T cell then
they are
going to elicit an immune response and
they would be known as immunogen's but
haptens
alone cannot do that so that is why
haptens are so simple they cannot
activate t-cells they cannot activate T
cells because they failed to bind to MHC
and to be presented to the T cells so
that is why they are not immunogen's by
themselves but happening can't be an
immunogen or they can be it turns out
that hapten can be an immunogen when
they're only conjugated with an adduct
and form an adduct and this experiment
was done by karl landsteiner but simply
he injected a rabbit with a putative
hapten so this is a symbol of the hapten
we are using right now and saw that in
the rabbit blood stream
there is no antibodies raised against
this hapten now
then he injected the rabbit with a
specific carrier a relatively complex
molecule which is able to bind to the
hapten but he first only injected the
carrier and so there is antibodies
raised against the carrier and when he
injected the rabbit with a combination
of both hapten and the carrier a totally
different antibody is raised which is
against the adduct the carrier and
hapten adapt so it turns out that
antibodies or immune response is going
to be generated only when hapten is
conjugated and forming an adduct a live
example let's just take a live example
so we know that contact time dermatitis
is formed by poison ivy right so when
poison ivy is sort of touching your
screen then our active molecule known as
URI shawl is going inside now your shawl
is nothing but a benzene derivative so
it is pretty simple in structure what
happens is when your shawl goes in its
an alcoholic form which is getting
oxidized inside the screen to form Queen
on
and this Queen own derivative is highly
highly reactive
now this Queen own derivative interacts
with the endogenous skin proteins and
form a hapten adduct this hapten adduct
this usual hapten adapt could be
recognized by specific Langerhans cells
and dendritic cells sitting in the skin
nearby and they can be presented to the
T cell and this u riche all attacked not
you ritual itself can elicit immune
response and this guy this particular
molecule is involved in delayed type 4
hypersensitivity reaction if you haven't
watched that video the link is given in
the description so that is how we
understand that hapten when conjugated
with proper carrier can elicit immune
response I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe I need some motivation please
like guys thank you